انفجار قوي هز محيط الجانب العسكري من
مطار كابول شديد التحصين هذا الجانب يضم
وزارات حكوميه وسفارات اجنبيه وقصر
الرئاسه قوه الامن طوقت المنطقه واغلقت
جميع الطرق المؤديه اليها
وقع انفجار صباح الاحد خارج مطار كابل
العسكري قتل واصيب فيه عدد من مواطنين
التحقيقات مازالت جاريه للكشف عن
المسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم تقول سلطات
طالبان ان الوضع الامني يتحسن منذ عودتها
الى السلطه اغسطس عام 2021
لكنها واجهت عشرات الانفجارات والهجمات
التي تبنا تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه العديد
منها حيث استهدف في الاسابيع الاخيره عددا
من المنشات الرئيسيه في كابول بما فيها
السفرتان الروسيه والباكستانيه بالاضافه
الى مكتب رئيس الوزراء السابق للبلاد وفي
الشهر الماضي
يبقى خمسه صينيين على الاقل بجروح عندما
اقتحم مسلحون فندقا يقيم فيه رجال الاعمال
في كابول واعلن التنظيم المتشدد مسئوليته
عن الهجوم